PROFESSOR: --questions about
what we've done.
I think it's been fast, but
hopefully if you understand
the principles, we didn't
go too fast.
But any questions on
what we've done?
I guess you haven't had
a chance to think
of questions yet.
Let me take care of our oddball
symmetry at the end of
the chart that I handed
out-- and this 4 bar--
and ask what we can do there.
Having discovered the four bar
operation in 2, 2, 2 with
diagonal mirror planes, we can
consider that as a new type of
symmetry element.
And this is the symbol for it.
And this would take a pair of
objects and repeat them by a
180 degree rotation.
And then another pair of
opposite handedness, opposite
chirality would be rotated 90
degrees and inverted, rotated
90 degrees and inverted.
And I mentioned last time that a
solid that has this shape is
something called a sphenoid.
And the 4 bar axis takes a pair
of faces that are up and
a pair of faces that are down
and skewed by 90 degrees.
Now what can we do?
If we add a mirror plane that's
perpendicular to the 4
bar axis, the right-handed
one goes down, the
left-handed one comes up.
And it becomes simply 4 over
m, which we've already got.
If we add a vertical mirror
plane through the 4 bar, if
you look a bit earlier at 4 bar
2m, now we've got the 4
bar, now we've got
the mirror plane.
Not surprisingly, we get
the two mirror planes.
And so S4v is going to be
the same as 4 bar 2m.
And that's something we
already have D2d.
So that exhausts the
possibilities.
4 bar just stands by itself.
At a vertical mirror plane,
it's D2d 4 bar 2m.
At a horizontal mirror plane,
it becomes 4 over m.
The diagonal mirror plane
is not possible.
There's nothing to place the
mirror plane diagonal to.
And if you add inversion, it
changes into 4 over m.
So this one is an odd group.
It sits by itself.
Except that we could start
there, and add a vertical
mirror plane, and get
4 bar 2m once more.
That leaves the cubic ones,
which are really easy to deal
with because a cube has
such high symmetry.
We all know what cubes
look like.
But when you show arrangements
of motifs, it gets a little
bit confusing.
So let's take a look at the
tetrahedral groups.
T is a combination of twofold
axes coming out in directions
corresponding to face
normals to a cube.
So these are the twofold axes.
And then there are threefold
axes coming out of directions
that correspond to the
face diagonal.
So this is the jack-o'-lantern
stereographic projection,
which is something I love to
draw at this time of year.
What will the pattern
look like?
Well, it's going to
look like 2, 2, 2.
So that's a subgroup.
So let's draw in a pair of
objects on either side of the
twofold axis, and that's
the pattern of 2, 2, 2.
Now this guy here is lurking
off of a threefold axis.
So that threefold axis is
going to repeat it three
locations that are 120
degrees apart.
And so there's going to be a
triangle of objects up above.
This threefold axis is going
to reproduce this into a
triangle of objects that
are down below.
The twofold axis will take this
triangle of objects and
move it over to here.
Also, up.
And the twofold axis that's
vertical will take this
triangle and move it down
to three that are below.
So it looks very complicated
in projection.
But it's simply a planar
triangle of atoms here rotated
180 degrees.
So you've got one like
this, one like this.
And then down below, two other
planar triangles of objects.
Remembering what the symmetry
of a tetrahedron looks like,
you can draw this arrangement of
symmetry elements relative
to a tetrahedron.
And the threefold axes
now are coming out
normal to the faces.
The twofold axes coming out
normal to the edges.
And imagine that we put a
triangle on this face, a
similar triangle on the face
behind, and a triangle
pointing in the other direction
down this way.
These are the three below.
So that's the pattern of 2, 3.
Take a tetrahedron, smack a
triangle on the two upper
faces, and an equilateral
triangle on
the two lower faces.
And the threefold axis that
comes out here comes out of
the center of this triangle
and out of the
center of this triangle.
The next one that you can
get from this is Th, the
tetrahedral arrangement
of axes with a
horizontal mirror plane.
If you put in a horizontal
mirror plane, it's going to
take this triangle and
reflect it down.
It's going to take this triangle
and reflect it up.
And they will overlap
in projection.
And so that's the
pattern for Th.
There's a mirror plane
perpendicular
to a twofold axis.
That creates an inversion
center.
So we can call this
a 3 bar axis.
So that's Th 2 over m 3 bar.
So just have triangles on the
upper and lower faces as well.
The one remaining one is Td.
Here are the twofold axes.
Here are the threefold axes.
And now if we put a diagonal
mirror plane in, diagonal with
respect to what?
Well, diagonal with respect
to these twofold axes.
So this mirror plane goes down
like this, passes through a
twofold axis.
There must be a mirror plane
90 degrees away.
And the threefold axis is going
to repeat these mirror
planes so that we get mirror
planes that are at an angle
with respect to the vertical
twofold axis.
And this is Td.
And this, in the international
notation, is called-- if we
can figure it out--
the diagonal mirror planes with
respect to these twofold
axes have changed them
into 4 bar axes.
So this is called 4 bar
3m, which doesn't
look cubic at all.
So that's a little
bit deceptive.
I am foolhardy for even
trying to do this.
And so I don't think
I'm going to do it.
4, 3, 2, we know what
that looks like.
That is fourfold axes coming
out in directions that
correspond to the face
normals to a cube.
A threefold axis coming
out of body diagonals.
Twofold axes between all of
the fourfold axes that are
normal to the edges
of the cube.
So all sorts of rotational
symmetry.
That, if you want a pattern, has
a triangle that's on about
each of the threefold axes.
But the one that is up, points
in the opposite orientation of
the one that's on the threefold
axis coming out of
the other end of the cube.
So you have one triangle
that's like this, up.
And another triangle like this
that's on the other end of the
threefold axis that points
down into the blackboard.
What can you add as
other extenders?
You can put in a mirror plane
that is perpendicular to the
fourfold axis.
And that leaves everything
unchanged.
Now we've got a mirror plane
passing through a fourfold
axis, so we have to
have mirror planes
at 45 degree intervals.
And that will create mirror
planes there.
This horizontal mirror plane
goes through this fourfold
axis, so there must be mirror
planes at 45 degree intervals.
So there's another one
like this and 90
degrees away as well.
The fourfold axis is
perpendicular to a mirror
plane, as are these other
twofold axes, so there's an
inversion center.
Here's a fourfold axis with a
vertical mirror plane going
through it.
And it has to have a vertical
mirror plane going like this
at 45 degrees away.
So that's the symmetry.
This is the regular symmetry
of a cube or an octahedron.
And I will not, even if
pressured, try to draw a
pattern that conforms to that.
We've got the fourfold axis
perpendicular to a mirror plane.
And this is called
O sub h, O with a
horizontal mirror plane.
The fourfold axis in 4, 3,
2 has got a mirror plane
perpendicular to it.
The twofold axes all pick
up mirror planes
perpendicular to them.
There's an inversion center at
the point of intersection.
So we label this axis
a 3 bar axis.
So that's O sub h, 4 over
m, 3 bar, 2 over m.
And this, as I say, is the
symmetry of a regular cube or
an octahedron.
Nothing else we can do here.
There's so many symmetry axes
all over the place that
there's no way we can snake in
any diagonal mirror plane.
Because there is no second axis
of the same kind adjacent
to either the twofold,
the threefold, or
the fourfold axis.
So we can't put a mirror plane
in here between the threefold
and the twofold.
We can't put a mirror plane in
here between the fourfold and
the twofold.
So we're done.
And this is the final and
30 second combination.
So there are 32 crystallographic
point groups.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So if m3m is a regular
operation, are there
symbols [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: O is the symbol
for 4, 3, 2.
And what we added as an extender
is a mirror plane
perpendicular to the
fourfold axis.
That is just one way of
adding an extender.
This is also Oi.
If we add an inversion center,
we get all this.
And if you look at the ones
have been honored by being
designated by a symbol, the
horizontal mirror plane takes
the precedence.
So for example, for 2 over m, 2
over m, 2 over m, you've got
two different vertical mirror
planes, and you've got one
horizontal mirror plane.
But it's called 2 over m,
2 over m, 2 over m.
You can call it 2,
2, 2, m, m, m.
That's also a possible symbol,
but much more of a mouthful.
There's some arbitrariness
to the symbol because the
arrangement of symmetry elements
is what's real.
And we decide how we
want to devise a
notation to label them.
And as we've seen, there are
two different people who
adopted a different code
for giving them names.
So if it's rational and
informative, it's a good notation.
Interestingly, the international
notation, on the
one hand, and the Schoenflies
notation, on the other,
complimentary.
The international notation
tells you
unambiguously what you have.
So 2, 2, 2 over m, m, m tells
you three orthogonal twofold
axes if you remember what
came out of [INAUDIBLE]
construction.
And perpendicular to each of
them is a mirror plane.
And that's what you've got.
Schoenflies tells you
how you derived it.
You took D2, and that's the
dihedral group 2, 2, 2, and
you added an h, a horizontal
mirror plane.
And all hell broke loose.
And you got mirror planes
perpendicular to all the
twofold axes.
So there's a certain
complementarity to the two
different notations.
And the people who do
diffraction and
crystallography for the most
part follow the international
notation, the Hermann-Mauguin
notation.
The people who do condensed
matter physics use the
Schoenflies notation.
Because it's more inscrutable.
And condensed matter physicists
like to be
inscrutable because it's
how you gain respect.
So both notation survive, but
are more prevalent in some
disciplines than in others
and vice versa.
Let's take a brief look ahead.
What remains to be done?
We now have the 32
crystallographic point groups.
These are the way things can be
arranged by symmetry about
a fixed point in space.
If we were to proceed in the
same way that we did for the
two-dimensional space groups,
what we should do next is
decide what sort of
three-dimensional space
lattices these symmetries
will require.
And then proceed to drop each of
the point groups into each
of the lattices that can
accommodate them.
And then use the tricks that
we've used in two dimensions,
take mirror planes and replace
them by glide planes.
And then having done that, we
would take the mirror planes
and the rotation axes
and interweave them.
And lest that job seem too
daunting, let me point out
that we already have 17
of the space groups.
All we have to do is take
the plane groups, take a
translation that's perpendicular
to the plane of
the plane group, and let all the
rotation axes and mirror
planes extend up indefinitely
in three dimensions parallel
to that translation.
So we already have 17 of the
three-dimensional space groups.
They look just like the plane
groups except they extend in a
direction that's perpendicular
to the plane of our original
two-dimensional group.
So we're already a long
way towards deriving a
three-dimensional space group
without really knowing it.
But what I would like to
consider next is the lattices
that are required for
three dimensions.
And I've already given you how
one can approach this problem.
Take the lattices that have
been required in the
two-dimensional plane groups.
And if the presence of a
threefold axis and the base of
the cell require, say, net
that is hexagonal with a1
equal to a2 identically in
magnitude and exactly at 120
degrees with respect
to one another.
Let's let the third translation
be perpendicular
to the base.
If it's hexagonal, we have
to have at least a
threefold axis here.
And we've found that adding a
threefold axis to that net
gave rise to two other threefold
axes in the center
of the triangle.
So one lattice would be one in
which the third translation,
which we'll label c,
is straight up.
In other words, perpendicular to
the net that we derived in
two dimensions.
What we will have as a
constraint is that if we pick
a certain translation that is
not normal to the plane group,
and let's say it terminates
here in projection.
So the third translation
goes up and over.
If there's a threefold axis at
this end of the translation,
there must be a threefold
axis at the end of that
translation.
And that mucks everything up,
and we no longer have a group.
We can't have another threefold
axis poking down
through the plane of this
two-dimensional plane group.
But it is perfectly OK if the
third translation moves this
threefold axis and puts down
a lattice point and another
threefold axis directly
over this one.
Or alternatively, another
choice for T3
would be this one.
That would put the lattice
point in a threefold axis
directly over this one.
So again, we have threefold axes
extending normal to the
plane of my drawing.
And I've created no
threefold axes.
So with a threefold axis, there
are three potentially
different space lattices, one in
which the third translation
is normal to the plane of the
plane group, another one where
the translation terminates
over the
other two twofold axes.
And so this is the way in which
one would proceed to
derive the space lattices.
Buerger does not
do it this way.
He doesn't look at
the plane groups.
He looks just at where the
axes sit in the nets.
No mirror planes whatsoever.
And I'll return to the point.
And the place where I think he's
wrong is that if you add
a twofold axis to a centered
net, you get twofold axes in
all of these locations.
These are the twofold
axes in C2mm.
And if that's all you look at,
there's no reason why this
should be the plane group.
And it looks as though you can
make T3 terminate over this
twofold axis.
And that would give you a
peculiar triple cell with
three lattice points along
the long diagonal of
a rectangular net.
And you say, wow, 15
space lattices.
We're going to be famous,
if not rich.
You can't do that because this
plane group can exist only if
there are mirror planes
in here like this.
And then through these twofold
axes, these have to be glides.
So you can't take 2mm and
put it on top of 2gg.
It's impossible.
So there are 14 space
lattices.
The 15th doesn't exist.
But it looks as though it's
possible in Buerger's
treatment when he looks just
at the placement of the
rotation axes alone and not
the location of any mirror
planes that are in
the plane groups.
So that is where we're
going to go next.
And that is a process
that actually is
surprisingly simple.
And we will get the space
lattices very quickly.
We'll get a number of space
groups along the way,
as we've just seen.
And then we will cut to the
bottom line and just look at
how this information is
tabulated in tables for you in
a fashion that's analogous to
the representation of the
plane groups.
So we're pretty close.
We'll be wrapping things up in
another two or three meetings.
What I would like to do in the
time that remains though, the
point groups are very difficult
to visualize unless
you look at real crystals.
So what I'm going to do is pass
around a collection of
models of actual crystals.
I'm not sure I can tell you what
every one of these models
represents.
These are curious things.
I would beg you not to
drop them on one
of the sharp corners.
These are made out of wood.
They're made out of pear wood in
the Black Forest by elves.
No, that last part
is not true.
But they are incredibly
expensive.
Because the angles in
these things have
to be exactly right.
So they are made on the same
sort of machine that you use
for faceting diamonds.
It's something that has two
degrees of freedom, so you can
get a surface that you want on
the material exactly parallel
to a grinding surface.
And then you have a provision
for advancing it normal to
that direction by a
controlled amount.
If it were not precise, you
would not see sharp edges and
sharp corners.
So these are incredibly
expensive.
I, therefore, ask it
that you hold them
tightly with both hands.
Don't drop them on the floor.
And I'll take around a couple
of handfuls of these.
I don't know if I have
enough for everyone.
With the tables of the point
groups in front of you, why
don't you try to identify the
point group that's possible in
each of these models.
This is a big one.
So I'm sure you won't
drop that one.
I don't think I have enough for
everyone, so I'll start
passing them out to every
other person.
Maybe you can look on with the
person adjacent to you.
Take one of these.
Pass those over.
Here you go.
I gave you that just
to be mean.
That is an example of something
that's called a
twinned crystal.
You can't have reentrant
faces.
Yeah, that's actually two
crystals that are intergrown.
AUDIENCE: So we can't identify
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You can look.
Block one of them out in your
mind, and try to imagine what
it would look like.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Here's an example
of another one.
That's actually gypsum.
And that's a very common
twin in gypsum.
And if you could take
this and rotate it--
this one doesn't rotate--
rotate it 90 degrees, then you
would have a crystal that had
a parallelogram shape.
And actually that's
been rotated by 90
degrees about an axis.
That's within the base.
AUDIENCE: No, no, I think that's
just 4m or 4 over m.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, there's
no mirror there.
That's a 4 bar, I think.
AUDIENCE: Oh, is that
the inversion?
PROFESSOR: There's
no-- neither.
I am a touchy-feely guy.
If I see something up here, I
look down here and try to feel
something that's
parallel to it.
But you're right,
you're right.
If I rotate 90 degrees--
remember rotoinversion is the
same as rotoreflection.
So I could rotate to here
and then reflect down,
and I get this one.
AUDIENCE: So it's 4 bar.
PROFESSOR: It's 4 bar, yeah.
And you see in the cross
section, it is square.
There's a little square on top
here, so there is a fourfold
aspect to it when you look
at planes in a special
orientation.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about 4 bar.
4 bar in planes are
twofold rotation.
PROFESSOR: A twofold
pure rotation.
Probably the best example of
4 bar is a tetrahedron.
Two faces on top, two faces
twisted 90 degrees, and
inverted down.
AUDIENCE: So that means
an 8 bar would be a
fourfold proper rotation.
So why cannot I put an 8
bar in the point group?
Because it's only a fourfold
rotation, and that's allowed.
PROFESSOR: The reason is that
there's no origin to
translations.
So if you had translations in
an 8 bar crystal, you would
have four translations that were
repeated by rotation and
then another translation 45
degrees and inverted down.
But you can assemble those
at this same point.
So you would have eight
translations 45 degrees apart.
And that's impossible
in a lattice.
Need another one?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: Do you need another
one to look at?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm good.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I can't have you just sitting
there doing nothing.
AUDIENCE: So is this half of
this [INAUDIBLE] material?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's twinned
by a 180 degree
rotation on the 1, 1, 1 plane.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, the
1, 1, 1 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That is actually half
of an octahedron.
This is a-- whoops,
no, it's not.
Yes, it is.
No, I think that's just
the threefold--
3, 3, 3.
3 bar, 2 over m.
And it's been rotated by 180
degrees, which is not a
symmetry transformation.
So the 3 bar is rotated
180 degrees.
AUDIENCE: That's a
3 bar, 2 over m?
PROFESSOR: I think so.
I think it's a 3 bar here, a
face here, and a face down
below, inverted, 60
degrees away.
And they're mirror planes.
And there two full axes
perpendicular to those mirror
planes, I do believe.
AUDIENCE: I don't see
the twofold axes.
PROFESSOR: You're only seeing
half the crystal, and I think
that's the reason why.
This is the mirror plane here.
And this edge is parallel
to that mirror plane.
And there's a twofold axis that
comes out of the middle
of that edge.
You can't see it.
That edge.
And the mirror plane is exactly
parallel to that.
It's tough to see because you're
only seeing half of it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This [INAUDIBLE]?
This is a fourfold axis
perpendicular to a mirror plane.
There's a threefold axis coming
out here and a twofold
axis coming out here.
And there is a mirror plane
perpendicular to the fourfold
axis and perpendicular to the
twofold axis also under the
mirror plane.
So this is 4 over m,
3 bar, 2 over m.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's the
rotational symmetry.
But you get all sorts
of mirror planes
coming through here.
So really, it's this one.
Mirror plane this way, mirror
plane this way,
mirror plane this way.
So if we set it up relative to
this, there's the fourfold
coming out here, here's the
fourfold coming out here.
And there are mirror planes this
way and also this way, 45
degrees away.
Nothing to do?
Can I steal one that you're
not working with?
There's a--
AUDIENCE: This one
is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's 2, 3 with
no mirror planes.
Oh, no, no, that's not true.
No, that is 4 bar, 2m,
believe it or not.
Look at the three different
directions.
These two corners
are the same.
There's a little, tiny
line segment there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so there is
a mirror plane right here?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but there's no
mirror plane going through
the other edges.
So there's a mirror plane
here, mirror plane here.
And then there is twofold axes
coming out of this little
straight line segment here.
AUDIENCE: Really?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And that's different
from this.
So these two edges
are the same.
AUDIENCE: Where is the
principle axis?
PROFESSOR: The principle
axis would be this one.
AUDIENCE: This one?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So basically, I have
this mirror plane right here.
Then twofold axis in the
middle of the circle.
So now here, where is it?
PROFESSOR: Well,
it's hexagonal.
So you want to back
up a little bit.
Right there.
AUDIENCE: This one?
PROFESSOR: No, sorry.
This one.
Threefold axis, twofold.
That's perpendicular
to a mirror plane.
AUDIENCE: So here's
my mirror plane.
PROFESSOR: Coming right out
of this little edge here.
AUDIENCE: Let's say like this.
No mirror plane?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: Which one
is this one?
It's like this one.
PROFESSOR: Let's put
it right here.
Here is--
AUDIENCE: Like this?
PROFESSOR: No, you've got
to get it up like this.
OK.
There is a mirror plane.
AUDIENCE: No, this is not.
No, the mirror plane
is right here.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
It goes up like--
oh.
Let me get it set up here.
OK.
There is the mirror plane.
This face is different
from the others.
AUDIENCE: And the twofold
axes are on the edges.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So basically,
there are three
for one mirror plane.
PROFESSOR: Here are the mirror
planes coming through this
way, this way, this way.
They're 60 degrees apart.
AUDIENCE: You say there are
three mirror planes?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this one,
this one, and this one.
AUDIENCE: I don't agree.
This one is no mirror plane.
PROFESSOR: You're right.
You're right.
AUDIENCE: There is only one
when you look from above.
But there are two for
just [INAUDIBLE]
45 degrees-- or,
not 45 degrees.
That's a triangle.
PROFESSOR: It's a
terrible one.
AUDIENCE: Because if we decide
that the top is one, the
principle--
PROFESSOR: There's
a twofold axis.
That's a mirror plane, and
that's a mirror plane.
And it looks like it is 2nn.
I think it's 2nn.
AUDIENCE: OK.
There's nothing further?
PROFESSOR: Nothing further.
Got that one?
AUDIENCE: 4 bar 2m?
I had to look to find
a twofold axis.
That was the tricky part.
PROFESSOR: No, no
threefold axis.
AUDIENCE: Well, twofold.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Finding those
was [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's it.
AUDIENCE: I can see
the mirror planes.
PROFESSOR: That's the
twofold axis.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And this two on top
and two underneath skewed by
90 degrees, that's a 4 bar.
So that's 4 bar 2m.
You have nothing to do?
Oh, you're talking
with them, OK.
AUDIENCE: What is this
one actually?
There is 4, 4, 2, 4, 3, 4, 3.
PROFESSOR: Right,
so it's cubic.
And mirror planes are going down
through the twofold axis.
So that's enough to tell
you that it is this.
So let's set it up here.
Fourfold axes are coming
out of the points.
So you've got mirror
planes this way,
mirror point 45 degrees.
Here is this twofold axis.
And here are the twofold axes
that are in the same plane.
And here's the other
fourfold axis.
AUDIENCE: I see.
That one's not fair.
This is actually two crystals
that are grown together by an
operation that is
not a symmetry
element of the crystal.
And actually these
two crystals have
symmetry 2 over m.
And they are rotated relative
to one another by
a 180 degree rotation.
It's not a symmetry element.
So this is something that's
called a twinned crystal.
AUDIENCE: Twinned?
PROFESSOR: Twinned crystal.
So it's really two of them.
And if I could twist this one
around so that the crystal
continued on in that direction,
it would be
something that had a
lozenge-like shape.
So I should put that one away.
That's only confusing people.
AUDIENCE: Professor Wuensch?
PROFESSOR: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Is that
a 6 over mmm?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's 6 over
m, 2 over m, 2 over m.
Six folds.
Two kinds of twofold,
one out of the edge,
one out of the corner.
And a mirror plane
perpendicular to each of those.
6 over m, 2 over m, 2 over m.
AUDIENCE: So that's the same
thing [INAUDIBLE].
So the 6 over m comes
from this way.
And then the 2 over
m is there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
it's [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
PROFESSOR: Let me put
that one away.
It's just confusing people.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that
one was easy.
PROFESSOR: That's a
twinned crystal.
It was easy?
You found it easy?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
3 over m, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I guess.
This looks as though it might be
the corner of an octahedron
because you don't
see much of it.
But these two faces and these
two faces are not related by a
fourfold rotation.
AUDIENCE: Well, either way,
there wouldn't be anywhere to
put a fourfold rotation.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So if you look at the whole
thing, this is actually two
intergrown crystals when
you see this sort
of reentrant angle.
This is two crystals grown
together by an operation which
is not a symmetry operation.
So this is something
that's called a
twin, a twinned crystal.
AUDIENCE: But the symmetry is
nevertheless 3 over m, correct?
PROFESSOR: Of the whole thing?
Yeah, yeah, of the
whole thing.
AUDIENCE: And this is just 3.
PROFESSOR: No, this is 3mm.
There's a mirror plane
down there and a
mirror plane down here.
AUDIENCE: You're right.
PROFESSOR: No twofold axis
because this end is different
from this end.
AUDIENCE: So this is a
regular solid, right?
What is it called?
PROFESSOR: This is a rhombic
dodecahedron.
AUDIENCE: Oh, the one you were
talking about the other day.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is 4, 3, 2.
And then mirror planes too
all over the place.
AUDIENCE: So all of these
solids do not have to be
members of this list, right?
Because these are
finite objects.
They can be [? twelvefold ?]
and--
PROFESSOR: They could be.
These actually, in fact,
are models of
real crystalline materials.
And they're made with the faces
and the relative sizes
that these minerals
actually have.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So somewhere floating
around is something
that's very characteristically
quartz.
And there's one that's a flat
one with a reentrant angle in
it, that's gypsum.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
fourfold.
Twofold here.
This goes into this.
No mirror planes because these
things are inclined.
So it's 4, 2, 2.
Good.
It's easy when you know
what to look for.
When you say, they are only
a few possibilities.
And if I see a fourfold axis in
it, that narrows it down to
two or three.
AUDIENCE: Like that.
That's an inversion center
running through here.
And there's no rotation
there [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] here?
Here through this way?
AUDIENCE: No, because this
doesn't map [INAUDIBLE].
Does that map that
by a mirror?
The mirror [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: It cuts
across this way.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
could buy that.
PROFESSOR: You've reached
a consensus?
AUDIENCE: We've got a mirror,
and we've got an inversion.
But we're not sure what
else we've got.
AUDIENCE: While I like
the inversion, I'd
also like the mirror.
I don't see the mirror.
All I see is a really an
inversion axis there.
I think I'm missing that mirror
that you're saying.
PROFESSOR: There's a mirror
that goes down this way.
And there's a twofold
axis here.
AUDIENCE: OK, that was
the one we missed.
PROFESSOR: So that's 2 over m.
AUDIENCE: Over m.
And the inversion
just falls out.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
in there too.
Inversions are nice.
You can feel inversions.
You put your finger on one face
and your finger on the
other face.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Get it?
AUDIENCE: So this is
this one, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes, very good.
And that is a silicate mineral
called garnet.
AUDIENCE: What's that?
PROFESSOR: Garnet.
It's actually a silicate
mineral, which is used as a
gemstone sometimes.
AUDIENCE: So this should
be a 4, 3, 2 face.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: But I don't know
if it's the end of the
[INAUDIBLE].
Could be m3m.
AUDIENCE: Where are the--
it doesn't an inversion
center.
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't have an
inversion center here.
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah, it does.
PROFESSOR: Oh yes, it does.
Yes, it does.
Actually, the thing to
look for are the
high symmetry things.
Your eye spots them.
That's got a fourfold
axis in it.
OK
So are there other
fourfold axes?
Yes, yes.
So that has to be based
on 4, 3, 2.
Because you have three
orthogonal fourfold axes.
Threefold is here.
Twofold axis is here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: There are--
oh, I already saw those ones.
PROFESSOR: You want to
look at some more?
AUDIENCE: All right.
PROFESSOR: Enough for one day?
AUDIENCE: Professor Wuensch,
I've been staring at this one
for such a long time.
And I couldn't match it
with anything on here.
PROFESSOR: This looks like a
tetrahedron except the face is
puckered up into this
little thing.
So the way I would start with
saying, OK, this is
tetrahedral in which case if I
make these things flat, that's
a perfect tetrahedron.
Four sides.
But what's happened is
that this face is
not quite 1, 1, 1.
The 4 bar axes come out these
three directions.
And they have got twofold
symmetry, mirror planes
running through the
twofold axes.
This is the 4 bar axis with
mirror planes running this
way, this way.
So this is actually 4 bar.
This is still further.
It's a cubic crystal.
This is based on the tetrahedral
symmetry.
Here is the 4 bar axis.
Mirror plane this way, mirror
plane this way.
Another 4 bar coming out
of these two edges.
And then these are the diagonal
mirror planes.
So this is it.
AUDIENCE: I think I was looking
for a threefold axis
in the center.
PROFESSOR: No, the 4 bar comes
out of the edge of the
tetrahedron.
And this is the other 4
bar coming out here.
Threefold like this and mirror
planes going through the
threefold axis like that.
AUDIENCE: I see it.
PROFESSOR: It's hard when
you look at this thing.
I never saw this thing before.
What's here?
But if you know the results
have to be 1 of these 32
possibilities, and this is
obviously cubic, and it's
based on the tetrahedron, that
means there are only three
possibilities.
No mirror planes.
If you find one mirror plane,
you ask yourself, does the
mirror plane go through the
threefold axis, or does it
miss the threefold axis?
It goes through the threefold
axis, so it's got to be this.
And then you know just
what to look for.
AUDIENCE: Is it just
[INAUDIBLE] m?
PROFESSOR: This is
a dirty one.
This is a dirty one.
If you look at this very
carefully, this face is the
same as this face, but it's
not the same as that one.
It's a little bigger.
So if you say, what's in here,
these two things do not come
together at a common vertex
like these two.
There's another little line
segment between these faces.
So there are no threefold
axes coming out of this.
Looks like it might
be tetrahedral.
Clearly, a mirror plane
going this way.
And then there is also a twofold
axis coming out here.
So there's a 2 over m and
another 2 over m.
I did this once before with
somebody, and this is the
hardest one in the whole set.
So a mirror plane this way.
There's got to be another mirror
plane because there's a
twofold axis.
4 bar.
Up, down, up, down.
So this is 4 bar, 2 over m.
4 bar, 2 over m.